[Music]
so I go out to Africa all the time and
regularly bring teams out we went out on
the 16th of July with some of our
success students staff my brother his
wife and before we went off to do the
projects and go to the bush for our 12
hour journey we had a team-building
exercise which was water rafting but it
turned out to be like a horror near the
absolutely disastrous the boat capsized
myself and the whole team ended up
falling down a waterfall 20 feet
waterfall I broke my rope my kneecap
badly lost 25% of my blood and was in a
real bad way
luckily the rest of the team weren't too
bad but it shook everybody up so we've
obviously assessed everybody men must
have been speaking you're not gonna
normally ask how y'all doing how y'all
feel I'm not going to ask that because I
know the answer
everybody's feeling you know sore
hungry tired thirsty shut up
scared confused basically every bad
possible feeling you could be feeling
probably people are feeling right now
but I want to remind you of what I said
yesterday I said yesterday that
throughout this week there'd be a time
in the week when we wanted to quit and
we wanted to turn back did I say that
yesterday yeah and right now probably is
that moment where we want to we want to
turn back we want to give up yesterday
we're talking about being soldiers I
mean warriors and we said a warrior acts
in spite of their mood and no obstacle
can get in their way
it's alright saying that in the
classroom and share in and stuff like
that but right now we're now going to
live that and that's one of the reasons
why we've run these camps we run this
camp because we're putting into practice
what we teach in the classroom about
determination about not giving up all
these things so I know that we've all
been a bit hurt and stuff like that but
is anybody - physically injured to
travel tomorrow and then yeah you're
good you know unfortunately I'm too busy
I physically can't travel tomorrow
because I've got to have an operation
I'm going to be in hospital for ten days
and it's gonna take quite I'm going to
be the cast's can take quite a bit of
time for me to get recovered but you
know what I'm a warrior so to me that's
an I eat that stuff up for breakfast I'm
not too worried about that what I am
worried about in fact this pain right
now my knee which I know is going to go
in a month
reminds me of the pain of the kids and
the orphans that we're going to go and
help this week where their pain lasts a
lifetime and we're going out there this
week to fix that problem to give water
to the thirsty people to provide shelter
to the homeless to be able to support
orphans tell budding entrepreneurs that
have nothing I've got five thousand
pound like what a solid and I want you
guys I need you guys help
spend that wisely this week so I'll pass
the baton on to Russell to team lead the
part of being a warrior is acting in
spite of your mood he's acting in spite
of any obstacle we did not come for a
jolly this week we came on a mission and
this will not stop the mission and like
the ants we're not going to go back so I
can't go out tomorrow it's fitting that
come on I'd love to but I'm calm I'm
confident in all of you guys to make
this happen there's there's boreholes
we're going to be digging
tomorrow we're going to be sorry
pointing diggers in villages of no water
Charles's village will be there tomorrow
night there's so much you need and
there's so little people the harvest is
plentiful but the workers are few and
you guys are here right now we're gonna
start heading there tonight right and
then now we'll go in trouble a couple of
hours down towards towards our final
destination will stop over to hotel and
then we'll do the rest of the journey
tomorrow just to break it up a little
bit but I think you need to get on it
straightaway otherwise we're gonna sit
here moping this is gonna lead the way
Charles Steve we're going to be hanging
your backs on me here praying like crazy
for you guys on the road and I'll be
giving you video updates every day have
to say it was an experience that
possibly work choose to repeat yeah it
was very very talk
I started out great
and then we were all on a boat and we
live sometime later that that boat was
likely overloaded and as a consequence
when we got to the top of a waterfall
that boat capsized and we kind of all
went bouncing down the rocks and yeah it
was it was very scary actually
and Samuel was hit very badly in fact
everybody had something that actually
you know here is equivalent to also it
was very tough mentally to be quite
honest just massive so I was very very
I'm also like maybe quite grateful very
grateful for everything you know in my
life something else fairly soon
I wasn't going to despite that me and
and drifted off away from everyone else
and we ended forth me and Anna ended up
onto a second set of Rapids and the
second set of rocks and we ended up
about I don't actually know the distance
but it was far I think it was probably a
kilometer away from everybody else down
the River Nile and to say that I wasn't
scared would be a complete
I've got a bit of news on Samuel now as
well touching this morning
he sends a video is obviously he's in
high spirits his injury is actually
worse than they thought it was yesterday
he has shattered his beat up as well
it's only gonna be about a year before
he's walking here
that here is pretty bad is actually four
places shut the shut the whole orbit
Ella those they reckon you should be
able to travel back he's gonna be in
plaster and stuff they reckon they'll be
imposter for about six to nine months
but the hill and their economy exactly
what he said to me only here he's
walking improperly he'll be on crutches
and stuff so he's really bad but at the
same time he's really keen with you know
that we could go out and and that's much
what we're here to birth so it's what we
do today yesterday warriors remember do
them so but every once in a map kind of
yes so this is very well in Entebbe to
the airport so we love this yesterday we
drove up through Kampala all the way to
ginger where we all nearly died
we then left ginger we've come back when
we're right now in the capital in
Kampala so that was the that was the
route we did yesterday
today we're going there so we're gonna
be going in having to look for anything
out what the need is same time we dig a
ball which will be led by Charles
because he'll know what the crack is
it'll be a good chance to see which will
just we think you need needed the most
now didn't meet I go back and do more a
lot down line but we've got five grand
left now digs for holes or whatever it
is that we think Andres table thought if
you'll give us a chance let's pick up
some bits anyway I just want to break up
the journey and he makes me along that's
good today is just about travelling
really and then we're gonna be staying
at our hotel
I believe in Kavala tonight and then
we'll be staying in the actual village
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so we're staying in Kabbalah at the
moment these this is one of the hots
that Mustaine if they're really they're
really nice actually the fast roof it's
really different to what we used to back
home later on today we're gonna be
heading across the lake like blood but
yeah I don't know why Cochran unique of
course but allowed to use small island
then but but that horrible yeah we're
heading straight across the lake just
either that way over there which is the
village that wit that we're going to
this is the village that we've been to
before I've never personally been with
Samuel has knees and there's a borehole
out there which is very interesting to
see that and see how that's affecting
the verge and then after we've been
there and spent some time with them
we're gonna be going looking at other
villages that maybe we can we can help
head over to the village we're just
hearing Kabbalah just buy some supplies
toys pens paper soap still to take over
the kids so excited to get moving now so
I'm just gonna head off into the food
market
[Music]
Heights are about to leave on the boat
now across the river
some people are a little bit nervous
about getting the boat after what's
happened but I'm sure it'll be fine and
hopefully won't capsize before got a
waterfall again we're gonna be all good
just really afford to get in there now
so I want to get moving
[Music]
co-come way got bit nervous little while
or maybe work I'm expecting maybe I'm
worried about what they're expecting but
yeah that's now I'm really hot I'm very
excited I'm pretty looking forward
seeing them I've been welcomed by them
and then gonna see exactly how they live
we can help
pretty pretty exciting forward to it
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
it's done
[Music]
[Music]
it's one of the every family must eat
this kind of food with beans and they
bring in their and they put miss
tuppence the beans it's a nice meal if
we bring the rice yeah and maybe think
of like bring that could meet or
something all the time that we know is
the common meal okay yeah this village
that we went to is where Charles was
brought up
so Charles does a lot of work with with
the without finish and continues to do
so he was brought up there his parents
died so he became an orphan and he went
out to live in a nearby town little much
about life out there got a job and what
he's doing is he's going back to the
village to give back because he knows
the people there he knows what it's like
to live on that page and he's you know
selfless guy who's caring about other
people know him I can help in the mass
that's kind of what Charles do he goes
every Saturday provides them all with a
good meal so they have one at least one
really good meal a week I believe it's
every Saturday he goes over with food
and he feeds them all of his own money
he paid for that with help from various
charities but he pays for the majority
of that and he is selfless he's every
week he's they are feeding them for this
so before Charles why
would not be not much branch itself I
will just float around now it would go
yeah look around by themselves thank you
good job there's a good job yeah the
children that come here for different
places
yeah we have got different villages here
we have the same community I mean from
the different villages but the same
community because we know each other
yeah so that's why like they have
different from the coming up the hills
others this side in the negative smaller
antennas like 5 stars
ding because according to the edge yes
very much
some people around as we have been when
they come and pitch from here
yes that we need more because people
days travel a long distance yeah coming
pitch-water
yeah so where did I travel where did I
travel so we could have one of them of
the help yes we have another tank up
there in the rain falls down the gutters
would be very big would the minute you
do get a lot of water to the tank and
maybe like any one or two days the tank
is full and then can be on of row but
then if they will be used and what about
that time from the tank then it would
mean that still the water won't be like
overflow because they are using it from
the tank all the time yeah yeah they
look of course they have to look just in
case maybe during that night and break
in place Oh open it in tomorrow find and
funders know what are in the time of
different hats or events like that oh
maybe a child
it is common sight in crap so in case
maybe someone comes to can get one safe
clean water or fetching
[Applause]
so we go our pens and sweets and suffer
I have no idea just how many children
are gonna babies that open books and
stuff it's an awkward marking or where
it's like yeah we've got all these book
for em enough for everyone and you can't
just go willy-nilly handing out some
surface it was good we managed to get
enough so I think everyone has a sweets
and a pen and they're like delighted
with that there's a shame because of all
this other stuff that we actually taught
hand out so it's hard I mean we when we
first I turned a little bit chaotic so
the guys that still step in and hand it
out for us both it was good it's amazing
how much of linking a pencil community
immune to these kids just shows really
how little they've actually the food
situation I was expecting to be as it
was really mean
the kids were all hungry they are still
hungry mate they're coming back for more
we've given them all to sweets and then
the fighting over the sweets which is
not nice and they're just hungry little
children the children man at the end the
day they're not these are not these
children observers what is the time
[Music]
which kind of two point five here are
some other thanks you can make with this
the big tank up there yeah what would be
the total cost for all building it is
someone sit down and you know a roughly
how much did this tank cost roughly 700
to 1500 pounds you hear people say
things like are well it's never going to
make a difference well it will to it
will to the people that it does make a
difference to so if you if you provide
water to a village it's gonna make a
damn big difference to that village and
yes it's a big project and and yes to
tackle the whole or even Uganda the
we're not going to tackle the whole of
Uganda but the people that we can help
it will make a big difference
ok so this is the room we slept then it
was they've got a little three-bedroom
house up here and it's obviously made of
their local months or he so mix but is a
pretty decent sort of our house far for
em rural Bush Uganda a comfortable and
to be honest it's not something I do
regular but these guys after all their
life so it does make me appreciate a
good bed that's all I'll say
so we've just spent the night in
Charles's house and we're standing here
with this village and we're now gonna go
walk I think about half an hour walk to
another village nearby where I believe
they need water and probably more than
they do here to be very very interesting
to see what he's like whilst the village
is still not fully developed after the
work that Samuel and Charles have been
doing over the last few years it's
improved massively we decided now to see
what the other villages are like and
assess our next project you have clay
here tomato no no we have the mini town
did this brick you bring this from the
town or you make them no make them from
here and could you make a tank from
these bricks but then have something
inside to make it line to make it
watertight so even though you make the
surround yeah can you make something
then these bricks yeah just for building
houses right but for the water they are
not good yeah yeah this won't maybe to
build water tanks with bricks they go to
town they get two bricks and transport
[Music]
[Music]
so I remember watching the video where
Samuel came here a couple years ago
watching him struggle at the health and
think you know what a pansy but look if
just walk something ever it is he is
pretty hardcore we just got to the
church I'm amazed the church really this
beautiful building in Italy with windows
wouldn't look out of place here in the
UK we go to a little village after this
but it's been really really interesting
inspiring journey so far look forward to
seeing what God offers at the church
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I was expecting it to be more or less
what was like apart from the fact I was
expecting it more like the video before
so I was expecting
they looked healthier than I was
imagining them to be I mean obviously
there are different parts when weary
when I'm talking about the village that
we stayed at now over parts of Uganda
it's still like I imagined it is still
they are still in need of water it's not
the whole problem is cured I'm literally
just talking about the village that we
stayed in that yeah it's more or less
what I imagined it Allah sees in the
video from the year before so I knew
roughly where if the biggest standout
probably was how hilly it was they must
be so fit walking up those hills poor
Alastair was struggling
fortunately Samuel has previously been
to this village and he's installed water
tanks with Charles's help and the
results seen the results of that water
that this village is now got is for them
it's being completely life-changing they
no longer have our a lack of water and
clean drinking water on the island some
of the kids are just brilliant man and
they're not although they still have a
lack there now fed weekly by Charles who
goes every week to feed them in taste
bread and things out there and obviously
they have that constant supply of
drinking water from from Samuel watch
Titus
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
many fail
[Music]
how you doing darling yes it's much to
this week that I believe how are you
some of you I am I mean I had it other
some scares but now all's good and been
thinking about you guys so um yeah
everything's what's the craic then wave
because Mandy was saying like looking
out the surgery was doing a little bit a
bit ropey I'm doing I'm trying
currently together swing them so they
can reassess but I'm in troubles because
no airline wants to take me on a quote
from under is jet which is just over a
hundred grand Wow so it's a bit steep so
that's like a bit of a last resort but
yeah and and I'm just praying I get
better okay what was cases they'll just
operate me again tell you about it well
he was worried today my whole my whole
focus has been trying to get on a flight
home so all the airlines refused me when
I got here the doctor is basically
working on my behalf to try and get me
get me back with a doctor's nose
KLM accepted I can go home there's a lot
of red tape sore a roof of a lot better
calum or an airline company very big
earrings
yeah so they've accepted take me home
business class I'll go with mom but it's
gonna be a bitter struggle so I've got
for instance I've gotta prove that I can
I can walk the distance of the seat to
the toilet I'm crutches myself I've
gotta prove I can do that so the doctor
tells me towards Quidditch
I can't unfortunately Sammy was stuck in
a hospital on his own for ten days
before being accepted on a flight home
upon returning to the UK he was sent
straight to hospital and was told he'd
lost 25% of his blood so yo vich aaja
village although it was late there's
lots of different options as to what we
spend the money on what you guys think
I think me was the village is progressed
clearly the Realtors made huge and when
we would talk to village to go and head
last night he was talking about waters
the first priority and then education is
the second role compared to the videos
we've seen before I didn't see any that
were like really really malnutrition
either no you're right they were skinny
and close the goods yeah they looked
like reasonably healthy happy young
children I think everyone can certainly
potentially fun with the villagers
some of the stuffs I had now though like
they all had electricity little had
lights saw the pillow yeah I was really
impressed really religious come on a lot
the only unemployed down to is the fact
that because they've got the water it's
free to their time focus on water water
water if it goes this fit goes well will
help people understand is this bearable
hopefully people will be able to help
them seed something that's going to grow
on and I love the idea of you not to
give jobs or and or maybe slightly just
sponsor somebody in their village to go
to have further education the business
yeah number that you've got set aside
for pale figure any of ours if we wanted
to if we wanted to like index to the
business we're free to do so yeah yeah
we that I want to invest in some way
tomorrow
so one of the things that we really want
to do here in Uganda is to help the
business people cuz I believe the
entrepreneurs are the backbone of any
society so if we can help people create
businesses it means they can AG give
back to the community but big it means
not only employing people they all add
to community as well so it's really
beneficial so it's good business people
that's why they're here today we'll give
them starting that soon I think we're
starting in about half an hour or so
people who already started arriving it's
the conference room that will ask me
exciting day everyone that's here was
getting up and speaking at least a
little bit to give them some experience
it's gonna be a shame the Samuel can't
be here because I think that have been
really good but y'all have a great day
anyway so we have to get started very
very shortly currently in Uganda ready
to do a business workshop with some of
the local people in the town kabali
we're doing it to try and help the local
population with business but we've
noticed are quite a few of the people do
not have pens and paper obviously this
is a bit of a problem so to give them
the best chance and to allow them to
learn as much as possible we have bought
I've just personally gone out and bought
some pens and paper for them we've come
back and they're distributed out the
people very thankful for this because
obviously it will allow them to take
more from the experience definitely
looking forward to a excuse can start
very soon we're just not sure what to
expect really people are coming in and
speak really and I think today I just
hope many people can take away as much
as possible from the day and maybe
improve their lives and improve the
community around them um little bit
nervous because I'm hosting the event
and my expectations are hopefully
there'll be at least one or two people
in the room who take away some lot and
uh get something go out and go and start
with a look at their little business
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so today's the last day of Uganda we've
carried out our mission we've carried
out our charity work it's been a
massively up-and-down week we've had a
bit of an emotional roller coaster with
water raft an accident
Samuel being in hospital traveling 1012
hours to get to villages so yeah it's
been a great week we're now all about to
leave Uganda for the last time and
probably sat a lot bit sad to see it go
but also glad to get home I think the
best way of summing this week up is
probably the good the bad and the ugly
so start off with the good the good is
that we we managed to get out into the
villages we've seen the good work been
done so far the village transit you
watch what it was like two years ago
transformed that the children have
swollen bellies they've got all clean
water they were all having a meal every
single day is it's an it's brilliant
also good is we've managed to find
somewhere else we can put a water tank
and we found somewhere to put a borehole
as well which means we'll be able to
help more people and transform our lives
which is great that's been the good the
bad one was the water rafting experience
where we capsized fell down the
waterfall hit the rocks I don't know
yeah that's pretty bad and the ugly I've
got a picture of it here on my phone you
probably won't pick it up but it's gonna
fly up on the screen now that Samuels
like that it's certainly lovely it's
been very interesting week but a lot of
ups and downs you always do when you put
yourself out there and problems always
come which is what has happened to us
but this week was about you know
building character and everyone's been
brilliant a bit I had a whole bunch of
warriors for us so I'm really happy with
how we've got on and I'm excited to come
back again just give as much as you can
guys these kids have nothing and
actually seen it with my own eyes is
painful and so just give everything you
can man so final thoughts are in the at
the at the outstanding moment in terms
of the success stood out the most to me
obviously was the absolute miss Samuel
on his leg
and also that's a really bad thing
there has been will looking at the back
now there have been positive outcomes as
a result of that
overall there's a negative thing but I
suppose I suppose a takeaway from from
the whole trip is even when you know
good things can come of of really bad
situations and you might have a really
bad situation like Samuels leg where
you'd go away how possibly could you
look at that as good and isn't good is a
bad thing but they happen you know you
do get positive outcomes out of bad
situations so I'd say that was a little
bit of a final thought albeit still a
terrible thing and I think he's doing so
well where he is now with his walking
and everything you know with what the
doctors said yeah new thing is don't go
whitewater rafting
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]